soir
ça va ouais t'as pas vu poelvoorde là le
belge n'allait pas il est ou n'est pas
salut ça va bonsoir ça va vous mangez
s'avoue jamais encore bien je fais plein
américain
tu vas bien tiré
bonsoir bonsoir je fais quoi la
communication
quant à chaque création j'ai mon épouse
coralie non c'est après le téléphone du
rib alors
ouais comment tu vas ça lui tirer un
ouais
ouais ça va très bien le chèque
poelvoorde là je connais pas mon genre
vambre cool board dont le petit grégory
c'est arrivé près de chez moi
20 vous prenez à il ya un mec qui
s'appelle ttbm il paraît que c'est à
dire très bien montée c'est un magasin à
côté à tout à l'heure tiens on va
demander du ketchup
savait difficile de franchir la barrière
[Musique]
bah oui je comprend une caméra sur ces
lieux
on va voir du ketchup
jeu nous en apporter et puis du
champagne
vous avez du champagne californien du
champagne vient de fort bien
[Musique]
on va avoir du ketchup et du champagne
californiens
n'ont en outre demandé
j'ai été la révélation de la rentrée
quand même oui ouais sans doute pour ça
qu'on appelle beaucoup
dont un peu d'argent de trois mois avant
deux avant de faire
c'est arrivé près de chez vous je
faisais du café-théâtre n'ont jamais non
non non non non avant de faire c'est
arrivé près de chez vous
oui
c'est moi oui
ni non ce matin je vous écoute dit moi
une maman a et c'est quelqu'un qui
aimait bien les news est allé
bas vous étiez pas nombreux programmes
dire quand même allé le dire avant
de compter dix mois alors qu'est ce que
tu faisais avant de faire c'est arrivé
près de chez vous dis que ça nous a
carrément au plafond ce film
tiré du dessin pendant les fier de te
rencontrer très heureux parce que
vraiment sincèrement j'ai pas fait
fortune dans la flagornerie
mais je trouve ça très bien subi pendant
quatre sets et qu'on regarde merci
beaucoup voilà ça me fait très plaisir
c'est vrai et bien alors je faisais
avant je faisais du dessin pour enfants
et de la photo j'ai surtout une école de
communication mais je n'ai jamais si
j'ai perdu une exposition pour les
enfants pendant un an l équation pour
apprendre les dangers de la pollution et
puis quand elle s'était apparemment ça
servait à rien comprendre est ce que tu
bouffes
gbaya pollution alimentaire
et puis quand c'était terminé le film
est sorti à ce moment là ouais ou et le
film il a marché ou pas marché
il a bien fait parce qu'on ne
s'attendait pas du tout à ce succès la
voiture ouais je goûte plus pour rien tu
peux me tutoyer la boisson comme tu es
belle si tu veux pas non plus pourquoi
les belges te dois de près le belge tu
dois beaucoup le canadien a le belge
tout ça je le connais bien le belge
tétouan et en france on est très content
d'avoir des belges et des canadiens
parce qu'on ne sait plus quoi faire
heureusement il ya des communes belges
et chanteur canadien saeed secoue la
tête que
c'est vachement bien quand j'ai demandé
du champagne californiens ont indiqué
qu'ils allaient fournir
alors qu'est-ce qui fait sur scène
je te mange toutes les pommes de terre
non non non pas bon
je joue un homme
qui a qui attend vainement sa tente dans
un café ouais et qui souffre entre
autres de ne pas être reconnu dans son
métier et nous savons tous ce que c'est
mais en plus ils auront davantage de
savoir que sa femme elle est reconnue
dans ce qu'elle fait alors que pour lui
elle fait quelque chose de tout à fait
idiot
c'est à dire qu'elle fait je serai une
chanson idiote je me dis ça c'est sain
c'est mélissa et il souffre a laissé
tout cas su reprendre au score à
dimanche
mais pourquoi
alors
m c'est pas mélissa tout à fait coralie
s'est pas inspiré de coralie non non
coraline connais pas un succès que tu ne
connaîtraient pas au bien mieux bien
mieux on n'a pas besoin de chanter
ce qu'aime maroc à paris on met autant
de mal à trouver du champagne
une cigarette
c'était vraiment un moment atteint
encore alignement je vais qu'est ce que
tu vas faire pression mais je connais un
petit peu mais je crois que je te coupe
l'appétit
non regarde
mais c'est pas
brett hull bex et je crois que c'est de
ma faute on ne mange pas le partager
franchement
que sont la belgique c'est vachement
plus américaine avec la france la
belgique et plus américanisé que la fin
ouais non non non un truc comme ça on
n'a pas nous en belgique non non non non
pas du tout non non non la belgique
c'est bien belge quoi ouais c'est resté
très français la belgique
alors au salon annonce je suis d'accord
c'est bien mais
attention les mecs à là on sent la
tension ce rallye je veux absolument que
tu boivent du champagne
fort bien attention attention merci
beaucoup
diane
bon alors attention vous êtes prêts
attention tout le monde est prêt
1 2 3
et bien c'est très bon pas mal on s'est
foutu une école non c'est bon un chine
aux
champagnes californien
[Musique]
c'est ce qui l'a différent du champagne
français il est moins cher
il était cher parce que tu le vois ici
en californie les moins chers
c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'on dirait du sprite
c'est à la couleur du canada dry ça a le
goût du canal rai mais ça n'a pas de
prix de canada dry c'est du champagne
californien et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux